since we've been awarded the World Cup
it has been now 12 years
and Qatar has been subject to a campaign
systematic campaign starting from
bribing and and buying the World Cup
you know and now reaching to a level
where Qatar is called as an unfootable
Nation unfortunately what's your
personal view on the people who are
saying these things whether they be
professional footballers whether they be
politicians whether they be members of
the media why don't they just come and
see themselves and experience themselves
a preaching from a distance is not a
solution boy according to boycott the
World Cup or who are not coming to the
World Cup it's their decision at the end
of the day but why they would deprive
the people and the public from attending
and enjoying the World Cup so everyone
is football who should stay out of
politics
course I mean we we always say that you
know Sports should not never be
politicized what kind of message they
are sending for their own public if they
are just criticizing and preaching from
a distance what about their own problems
within their countries which they are
turning a blind eye and now they they
want you not to preach the world outside
honestly not me
but there is a lot of people
from around the world they are seeing
this is just a sense of arrogancy
a sense of people who cannot accept a
small country in the Middle East
has one uh the bit to host the World Cup
Harry Kane the England football captain
is going to wear a one love armband he's
not the only footballer who has come out
and said that they are going to make a
stance
what do you think about that
well first of all in the Patriots FIFA
rule is not our rules
this is just you know an international
in the pitch it's sub it's really uh for
the FIFA whatever they allow or not
allow it's not what Qatar allows or not
in the country we are welcoming
everybody
we are not discriminating anyone and
we've been saying this uh repeatingly
that everybody is welcome we would like
to invite everyone to come and to enjoy
the football and to enjoy the festivity
and the celebration
why everyone is expecting that other
discriminates someone or another all
what we are asking for we have our
cultural norms we have our society
and what they like and what they don't
like we are not going to change the
society for four weeks event yet we are
respecting everyone and expecting from
everyone to respect our laws you said to
respect qatar's cultures and lots it is
illegal to be homosexual in Qatar if
to respect our laws yes but if two men
or two women who go to the World Cup as
fans football fans
hold hands in a street
kiss in the street
what will happen to them
the law is this uh actually the laws
doesn't allow display of public
affection whether it's a man and man or
a man or woman that's that's our law
holding hands is not a display of Public
public eviction as far as I know if you
try and get an accurate figure for the
number of workers who have died during
the construction of the World Cup
infrastructure whether it's stadiums
Road whatsoever is anywhere between
three
and six and a half thousand
nobody seems to know the true figure why
why not well first of all the numbers of
the fatality in rotter is published is
published by the statistics Department
every year and it's classified
but we are not classifying the numbers
based on if they are labors or
categorizing the people when we are
reporting that the death that relates to
the World Cup R3 64 500 is uh untrue
number which beer reported and
unfortunately
has has not been verified and wasn't
reported responsibly and yet we've been
responding to this number that has been
untrue a few will count all the labors
there in the country one is too many 50
is is too much as well there are laws
there are regulations and there is an
implementation which is carried out by
the government why if any case that
happens in Qatar the government will be
blamed if the same exactly the same case
happened in Europe the companies will be
blamed here's the double standard which
we are trying to highlight que estarma
the leader of the opposition here big
football fan Arsenal season ticket
holder I think has said that he is not
going to go to Qatar
because he's taking a stand Prince
William
who is the president of the Football
Association here he's not going to Qatar
either are they misguided well it's it's
his decision at the end of the day uh we
of course look uh we have a very strong
relation and partnership with Britain
that's with the government with all the
political leaders in the country and we
have an open dialogue with them and we
have been always very open and very
welcoming for any constructive criticism
or comments and we've been working
together with them at the end of the day
it's their decision to decide whether to
come or not regarding press William as
far as I know he decided not to come
because of his calendar that doesn't
allow him this is this was there in the
announcement yet I don't I don't recall
that he has attended the last four four
World Cups as well Liberty is now
president of the fa and This World Cup's
not crept up upon us it could have been
in the calendar many many years ago well
uh I hope his his schedule will allow
and he will come to support England team
if they will qualify after the the the
mid the the video games